[Music]
some good Christine Aguilar making her
carpool karaoke debut tonight from court
ins
time time special and a shell Turner is
joining us right now from New York and
that is not the only musical moment that
Jesus rolling out right easy no but I
wanted to hear more of that that was
very Nancy I know right listen I was
exclusively on set though for the making
of his star-studded and sometimes
dangerous crosswalk the musical every
time we do it I'm like this is the
stupidest thing the last time I saw
Allison Janney was she was holding an
Oscar in her hand and now she's lying
the hills are alive with the sound of
music on a crosswalk a lot more work
than they thought it was gonna peak the
streets of LA are live with the sounds
of cordons crosswalk musical that's on a
ferris dressed like a milkmaid James and
the big bangs canal there are her cows
it took three hours eight cameras and
lots of movable props to shoot four
songs all done in between stoplight were
you ever fearful I feared for James's
safety when he decided to get in
someone's car and I felt very safe oh my
god this did you really jump in
somebody's card I didn't who that guy
was but I thought if he's be fun to get
in his car and drive off she's like dude
what are you doing
the mini musical also stars young
Sheldon's Ian Armitage so in the Corden
people call and say hey you want to come
play in traffic
I said maybe not the traffic yes
definitely it's all part of James
carpool karaoke primetime special airing
tonight Allison do your best no one's
expecting March and by the way the wig
works how do you think America is a good
hairline curve I miss Channing I don't
think so when you have an Oscar allison
janney you can have whatever type of wig
you want it doesn't matter right man
Steele is cute I like that little right
little pixie it does Ari DP thank you
very much
[Music]
[Applause]